Did the monkey just talk we need Kong the
world needs him godzilla will come for him
that would be a death sentence
I know chia is only a child she's the only
one he'll communicate with and we need Kong
here we go this won't end
until one of them submits
are you sure the monkey's gonna survive
this it's us I'd worry about
oh my god this is so massive
and this child she's the only
one he'll communicate with
we need kong the world needs
him to stop what's coming
it's godzilla
These are dangerous times godzilla's
out there and he's hurting people
and we don't know why there is something
provoking him that we're not seeing here
the myths are real there was a war
and they're the last ones standing
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
godzilla versus kong trailer video they dropped a
bunch of new footage so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will be doing
more videos for the movie when it comes out at
the end of the month too just a couple more
weeks to go but the new footage starts with
that full scene of godzilla showing up to fight
kong on the carriers earlier in the movie the
air force pilots try to slow him down with their
standard missiles but he just soaks the damage
and then swats them away like they're a couple
of flies even though we all expected this it's
hilarious how quickly he just blows through all
their ordinance all the battleships open fire on
him i think these are the 50 caliber guns i'm not
totally sure about that but they just want you to
see that they're unloading everything they have
on him as he swims up while they're carrying kong
predictably he uses his tail to smash through
two of the ships like it's no big deal one of the
anchors catches on his body and he takes half of
the ship for a ride underwater then you have kong
grabbing the other side of the anchor chain
and reeling it in like it's some kind of crazy
fishing line like he's fishing for godzilla's
got a real big one this time gotta bring it in
then godzilla comes swimming up to kong's ship
then presumably this is right before a kong
peeps over the side of the ship screams into the
water then godzilla surprises him by launching out
of the water and on to the top of the ships then
they start duking it out and kong winds up going
into the water floundering for a second until
he gets his bearings and if it wasn't clear
kong can swim at least canonically he can swim
we just haven't seen him do it in any of the
new films so far in the monster verse it's just
the whole idea with this first carrier fight is
they're trying to show you is that godzilla has
the big advantage because he's just at home in
water as he is on land in fact just because of
the way his body is because the way he carries
his weight around when he's on land i would
say he's actually a better fighter when he's in
water because he can still give off all the same
attacks when he's underwater he can still do his
atomic breath he can still do his atomic burst
all of his physical attacks work the exact same
but when he's in water he's not forced to carry
all that weight around with him so it's not quite
as much of a disadvantage the only real titans
that would have a big advantage on him in deep
water would be like your true water-based titans
like a giant octopus the director of the movie did
actually say there would be a clear winner in the
godzilla versus kong fight but here's the thing
with that i think he was specifically talking
about this first fight on the carriers here
i don't think he was talking about the entire
movie because there's clearly a bunch of different
fights during the film like first when they go
to pick up kong there's a couple fights in the
movie just to set up how badass he is then you
have the carrier fight with godzilla and kong
earlier in the film then you have all this footage
of the later fights when they're in the cities
and there's a couple different fights like
you have godzilla versus kong in the cities
then you have the whole idea of godzilla versus
mechagodzilla than the inevitable team-up where
godzilla and kong tag team mechagodzilla early
prediction before they both go their separate
ways similar to the ending of the 1960s king kong
vs godzilla movie you guys can let me know in the
comments though if you actually legit think that
at the end of the film after the final fights are
done after they take care of mechagodzilla there
will be a clear winner godzilla or kong the way
they're hyping it up though they make it seem like
kong goes down hard during this carrier fight like
godzilla is the clear winner but then kong rallies
later in the film and has a much better showing
during the mechagodzilla fight so by the end
of the film when he has a special axe and helps
take down mechagodzilla he comes out seeming like
more of a winner than he did earlier in the film
post all your theories about what that
means for godzilla during the film though
but then you have a bunch more footage of the
battles and some more footage of the hollow earth
which actually looks pretty fantastic you have
a little girl communicating with kong who's kind
of adopted her in his own giant way this footage
here is a little too dark so i can't tell exactly
which city godzilla's swimming up to this might be
one of the scenes where godzilla goes looking for
mechagodzilla and starts attacking these cities
or makes it seem like he's attacking cities and
they try to play it that way but really he's just
looking for where they're keeping mechagodzilla
to try and take it out and because it does seem
like they're going to continue with the godzilla
franchise just because it seems like they're
going to renew their license with touhou i am
wondering if they're ever going to do easter eggs
for godzilla offspring as well like maybe in some
of these future films you'll have people trying
to steal godzilla's offspring and then that's what
really pisses them off but i think most of the
idea in this film godzilla versus kong is that
godzilla is trying to get rid of mecha godzilla
then there's a bunch more footage of a couple of
the other different battles the carrier battle
then later in the movie in one of the cities
then a couple new scenes from that bigger fight
scene of godzilla versus kong inside what looks
like hong kong amongst all the neon signs with
him opening up in his atomic breath while kong is
using his new axe to absorb the energy it's hard
to tell when this hollow earth scene takes place
but i'm assuming it's earlier in the film when
they come to take kong they did see during this
movie we're going to learn more about the ancient
war of the titans like the ancient rivalry that
they keep referring to during all these trailers
that kong and godzilla had then you get that tag
scene of millie bobby brown and the others inside
the monarch facility and then that scene of them
just giving each other the classic challenge just
screaming in each other's faces like come on bro
bring it there were also some new images of
mega godzilla and some of the promo materials
as you would expect he's way more hardcore than
the classic versions of the character if this is
accurate it seems like it's pretty accurate to
what he looks like in the film just modernizing
him the same way that they modernized the designs
for kong godzilla and all the other titans in the
new films a lot of you were also commenting on my
earlier trailer videos too about how they tweaked
godzilla's design just a little bit because in the
earlier films at least in the newer monster verse
films like king of monsters his eyes don't light
up quite so much when he gives off his atomic
breath i'm assuming they're just doing that to
make him pop on screen just a little bit more
but a couple other details that we just learned
about the movie is that this first big godzilla
vs kong carrier fight lasts for 18 minutes but i
think that includes all the setup all the lead up
and then the aftermath as well it's not just 18
minutes of them punching and biting each other
that would be crazy like make all the jokes you
want about that epically long rowdy roddy piper
and keith david fight scene from they live it
just goes on and on forever but in all this
trailer footage when they keep talking about this
ancient history of the titans and the wars that
they had revealing more about the ancient cultures
that worshiped them as gods they're mostly talking
about godzilla and kong's ancestors like these
virgins that are fighting in this movie that we're
watching are just the latest generation of these
titans best example of that is during kong skull
island we saw the skeletons of kong's dead parents
the whole idea too the longer they live the bigger
they get so that's why kong is getting so much
bigger like he was a really young character
during the 1970s in that first kong skull island
movie godzilla would just keep getting bigger
and bigger the longer he lived so when they talk
about them being ancient rivals they're talking
about the rivalry between their two species for
the last several thousand years also if you guys
didn't see talking more about skull island stuff
future of the kong character netflix is actually
doing a skull island anime series they call
it anime but i think it's just anime inspired
it's being animated by powerhouse they're the same
company that does the netflix castlevania series
which is top tier animation it's also very anime
inspired but it's not actual anime no idea when
they're dropping episodes of that or which part
of the timeline it's going to take place in or
how it's going to fit into the canon i think it's
pretty safe to assume it'll take place sometime
before the events of godzilla vs kong and they'll
just use it to introduce a couple of new titans
and just a big reminder too because theaters are
starting to reopen if there are theaters near
you that are open they might actually be playing
the movie because they're releasing it on hbo max
and in theaters on the same day where theaters are
open but later this month we also have the justice
league snyder cut coming that's on march 18th and
then the day after that marvel's falcon and winter
soldier series drops on disney plus and i'll be
doing episode videos for that too so there is a
lot a lot of really big really cool stuff coming
this month 2021 looking so much better than 2020
so far if there are any other big easter eggs that
you spotted in this trailer footage that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments and i'll do more godzilla versus kong
trailer videos when they drop more footage while
you wait for everything click here for my brand
new Wandavision episode 9 trailer video and click
here for all my Wandavision finale predictions
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!